there is absolutely a strategy to draft
your fantasy football team specifically
with each of the positions if you listen
to me and you pay attention throughout
the year you'll have a shot of the title
by the end roughly 40 million people
play Fantasy Football and Matthew Barry
is the absolute expert so my name is
Matthew Bary and my official title is
senior fantasy and sports betting
analyst for NBC Sports and peacock how
often refer to the Godfather of fantasy
football Matthew Barry is going to take
us position by position highlighting
what stats make a successful fantasy
option when it comes to quarterbacks in
general what you want as dual thread
quarterbacks quarterbacks that not only
get you fantasy points with their arm
but with their legs last season of the
top six quarterbacks and fantasy points
per game four of them had 700 or more
rushing yards and in fact eight of the
top 10 fantasy quarterbacks at points
per game last year had at least 350
rushing yards you really want a dual
threat quarterback because if they don't
get you fantasy points with their legs
you need them to have 40 passing
touchdown upside and there just aren't a
lot of quarterbacks like that in the NFL
right now I also think it's important to
understand tiers Josh Allen Patrick
romes and Jaylen birds are kind of the
elite top three but there's a clear top
eight quarterbacks what you really want
is quarterbacks that run and throw that
have talent around them you can be the
best quarterback in the world but if you
got the worst offensive line it's hard
to throw from your back Josh Allen is a
great example Josh Allen had a bad
completion percentage they said he was
more of a runner than a thrower year
three Josh Allen gets Stephon digs one
of the best wide receivers in the NFL
what happens he becomes the number one
quarterback in fantasy everyone talks
about his accuracy his Elite passing did
Josh all suddenly become a better
quarterback yes he did having Stefon dig
to throw to makes you a better
quarterback for the running back
position bam is kick the top five
running backs and fantasy points per
game last season all had at least 310
touches 16 to the top 20 had at least
250 touches all finished as top 20
running backs in fantasy points per game
the next thing is what kind of touches
are they getting specifically we want to
look for high value touches receptions
and Red Zone touches are they getting
the ball when the team gets inside their
opponent's 20 yard line that's the red
zone are they getting it in goal to go
situations which is inside an opponent's
10 yard so ideally you want running
backs that touch the ball a lot and that
they touch the ball a lot when they get
close to the goal line and they touch
the ball a lot from their quarterback
not just on first and second down but
also on third down as part of the
passing
attack in terms of wide receiver that's
somebody that is earning a high
percentage of Target Target share and
targets for routes run wide receivers
need to have the ability to earn targets
by getting open the actual best wide
receivers in the NFL tend to be the ones
who scored the most fantasy points
Justin Jefferson Jamar Chase Cooper cup
Tyreek Hill Stefon digs those guys are
the best wide receivers in the NL and
they also are the ones who score the
most fantasy points if you want some
efficiency metrics if you want to get a
little bit dirty Target share targets
per route run yards for Route run are
all good efficiency metrics for wide
receivers wide receivers tend to be
safer early round picks due to
consistency and lower injury risk when
you think about it running backs are
being tackled hard they're going in
between the pile wide receiv receivers
they bounce out of bounds they're being
hit by a defensive back not an defensive
lineman wide receivers tend to have a
lower injury risk I also like rookies by
the way look at the second half rookie
wide receivers there's a number of
talented wide receivers who might start
slow as rookies but over the second half
of the year will have a huge impact if
you think about last year with guys like
Garrett Wilson Chris o Jan doson at
times that's another place to look for
as you get further into the
season and then at the tit end position
what you want is you want to see how
many Snaps are they out on a passing
play are they used primarily as a
blocker or they used as a passer some
Titans are really just glorified wide
receivers what's their opportunity we
can look at Talent they have a good
quarterback is the tight end used more
as a Blocker in this offense or is the
tight end used as a passing weapon in
the offense generally speaking I either
want to be one of the first people in my
leite to get a tight end or one of the
last because having an elite tight end
can be a huge huge Advantage Travis
Kelsey Mark Andrew TJ hackinson for me
are those top three I think they stand
up Above the
Rest we' spent a lot of time looking at
trying to predict kicker scoring and
kicker scoring year over year over year
and generally speaking the best kicker
in fantasy football and like the 12
kicker in fantasy football the
difference is like one and a half points
a game there's just not much difference
there's a lot of variants you like
kickers on good offenses you like
kickers that play indoors in warm
weather cities so they're not often
kicking in bad weather you can look at
defenses that give up the most field
goals that have good red zone defense
but bad defense in the middle of the
field you know kind of their B don't
break defenses their teams will come
down on the off and will kick but
generally speaking it doesn't make sense
to draft a kicker before the last
round with defenses You can predict some
things you can predict hey this is a
team that likes to Blitz a lot so
probably they'll generate you know some
sacks maybe a few more turnovers but
honestly it's generally fairly fluky if
you look at defensive scoring year after
year it rarely Carri from season to
season so streaming is always a much
better option than saying I'm going to
go out and Target this there are
defenses that we think are going to be
pretty good the Eagles and the nighers
but you're often better off of just
picking the defense that's playing in an
offense week after week now that you
have your team built let's get to the
most important part a fantasy team name
is very important right this is not a
decision take lightly the team name
should reflect your personality and
ideally insult somebody else in your
League fantasy football there is no one
right way to play there is no one one
right way to draft ultimately you have
to figure out what works for you and do
what you want to
do